so wait this is your fourth time on the
show so you get it
hold up on the show give it give it some
space
give it some space so give it some space
no you get this wonderful gift that we
give people
that have been here four times you're
welcome in advance come on justin oh my
god is it a car this is a team kelly
jacket
you're welcome thank you welcome take it
thank you what this is kim is this
is uh well it's leftovers from my season
are you kidding me this is my leftover
jacket
oh my god this is great but uh it's not
that good until you
sign it i'll sign it but no i heard that
you liked
you like tammy downs because i heard um
i heard you over
at your girlfriend's house and you know
what i'm talking about and you were
taking her rings
sherry you were taking her rings you
were taking all this i have video
footage
of you you were trying to help her pack
but really you were just taking all her
stuff
no no no no no okay sherry shepherd
takes my things and i'm actually going
back to her house
to get them back wait what you look
guilty in that video with those
bracelets
okay maybe those weren't maybe that was
worth the thing she took
but she has taken things and she's kept
them so i feel like it's only
fair for me to go and get some things
that i might need so like what
that i might need well i thought you
might need a jacket so i got you one
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure